recently Shaq made some comments on his
podcast that he apparently has a podcast
and the comments went viral led to a
fair amount of blowback during the
course of the conversation the NBA
legend cautioned men that they should
never be emotionally vulnerable in front
of a woman open up to a woman yeah never
no never when's the last time you think
you've opened up to a woman we don't
your whole life got players like like I
I could me and him relate it yeah this
our first time me I tell you guys
there's some connection here oh no they
gonna tell you you can't because you
know why but it's a trap because you
know why I'm trapped no no I'm I'm going
to tell you what cuz once you do
whenever something go down they're going
to throw it back in your face there's a
seed of Truth here that is in fact
Universal the problem with Shaq's point
is that it's it's too absolute he says
well it never open up never ever well if
you never open up to a woman at all then
you'll be entirely emotionally closed
off what with the rock this is an
extreme level of stoicism that even I
find excessive